je vous propose maintenant à l'occasion
des 30 ans de mai-68 cette rétrospective
des événements dans leur globalité du
vendredi 3 mai date des premières
échauffourées à l'évacuation de la
sorbonne et du panthéon à la mi juin
l'agitation en milieu universitaire vous
savez avait commencé en mars à nanterre
mais c'est réellement le 3 mai que
démarre le mouvement très rapidement et
s'étendra au monde ouvrier
c'est notre enquête de ce soir daniel
wolfromm c'est le premier pavé de mai 68
d'un coup le jeune homme fait mouche le
policier assis dans le car est atteint
en plein visage
il est 17h30 boulevard saint michel ce
vendredi 3 mai autour d'autres sont
prêts à en découdre
peu avant à l'intérieur de la sorbonne
un certain cohn bendit et une centaine
d'étudiants décident d'occuper la
faculté craignant des incidents le
recteur appelle la police qui embarque
tout le monde
la sorbonne et évacué au quartier latin
la nouvelle se répand vite les forces de
l'ordre en s'en sortir en tapant dans le
tas mais surprise
les manifestants accusent le coup et
contre attaque
lundi 6 mai daniel cohn bendit et sept
étudiants passent en conseil de
discipline
un quart d'heure plus tard la police
tente de disperser une manifestation de
solidarité
en vain
initiée le 22 mars à nanterre la crise
universitaire tourne à l'émeute
les négociateurs vont tenter de calmer
le jeu mais le gouvernement refuse de
rouvrir la sorbonne et les étudiants
restent mobilisés
nous demandons le froid mairie jusqu'au
faut pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
débordements sur les côtés vendredi 10
mais tout est prêt pour un nouvel
affrontement au soir commence la
première nuit des barricades
12 heures du matin six mille policiers
reçoivent l'ordre d'attaquer les
affrontements se poursuivent jusqu'à
l'aube des centaines de blessés de part
et d'autre près de 500 interpellations
et la désolation au coeur de la capitale
le premier ministre georges pompidou de
retour d'afghanistan
c'est alors des concessions mais la
révolte des bords du cadre étudiants les
syndicats ouvriers prennent le relais
lundi 13 images insolites georges séguy
presque au coude à coude avec daniel
cohn bendit
derrière trois cent mille manifestants
le plus gros défilés depuis la
libération
nous avons attiré plusieurs fois pour
vos séjours le caractère anti
capitaliste la sorbonne et réoccuper par
les étudiants pendant trois semaines au
coeur de paris elle sera l'emblème de la
commune de mai mardi 14 mai les deux
mille ouvriers de sud aviation près de
nantes vote une grève illimitée et
occupent les locaux
au même moment de leur côté les
métallurgistes de renault cléon près de
rouen b braille
mais justin ont quand même 14 h 30 vous
pourrez me reposer et profite d'une
faute grave heureusement de lazard
d'amélioration réduction des cadences en
deux jours la france s'arrête paralysé
par le plus grand mouvement social
depuis trente-six pour couronner le tout
lyon est envahie par la foule pendant un
mois le théâtre se transforme en
spectacle permanent du temps d'en réunir
maintenant diminue décidé d'une vraie
discussion
l'histoire s'accélère 3 6 10 millions de
grévistes le 20 mai le pays est paralysé
une décision du ministre de l'intérieur
christian fouchet va de nouveau
mobilisés une partie de la jeunesse
l'expulsion vers l'allemagne de daniel
cohn bendit en pleine crise sociale
déclenché le 24 mai la deuxième nuit des
barricades
ces images mêlée au projet avorté de
référendum proposé par le général de
gaulle par est sonné le glas du régime
mais c'est un trompe l'oeil certes on
relève deux morts l'un à paris l'autre à
lyon mais ces carcasses de voitures ses
vitrines défoncées
ces arbres coupés vont retourner cette
fois la france profonde contre les
étudiants
le lendemain une fois l'homme du jour
celui vers lequel la gauche non
communiste et une partie de la jeunesse
paraît se tourner c'est lui
pierre mendès-france l'ancien président
du conseil mais après le meeting de
charléty mains d'aes la figure de proue
du psu refuse l aventure politique
croyant alors son heure arrivée françois
mitterrand lui se jette à l'eau
je propose un gouvernement provisoire de
transition et de gestion soit aussitôt
mise en place c'est dans cette
atmosphère trouble que de gaulle
disparaît quelques heures le 29 mai à
baden baden saisi par le vide politique
la france conservatrice val soutenir
massivement dans les circonstances
présentes je ne me retirerai pas cinq
cent mille manifestants sur les
champs-elysées après ce succès
gaullistes et les accords de grenelle
qui prévoit d'importantes hausses de
salaires les travailleurs vont accepter
la reprise
le mouvement va s'effilocher pendant
tout le mois de juin malgré la mort de
deux métallos à sochaux est celle d'un
lycéen à flins
vendredi 14 juin la messe est dite
l'odéon et évacué dans l'indifférence
générale deux semaines plus tard les
élections législatives consacreront le
raz-de-marée gaulliste et une défaite
humiliante pour la gauche
épilogue douloureux pour ceux qui
croyaient alors que la vie elle est
immédiatement changé il ne pouvait pas
se douter que leurs idées allaient faire
leur chemin dans la société tout entière